welcome back to gamespot's coverage of
e3 2021 as part of play for all it is my
great pleasure to be joined by
pete hines svp of global marketing and
comms at bethesda aka
uncle p aka the keeper of secrets over
at bethesda how are you doing
i'm doing well trying to keep all the
secrets i can i'm gonna do my best to
pry at least one out
i've interviewed you before and i know
how hard this is but i'm gonna take
i've been training for you for a year
now i'm gonna see what i can do
so i'm not rooting again dishonored
three is it happening or not
i don't know damn i failed at the first
attempt
um yeah so the microsoft and bethesda
press conference a big
big kind of moment for you coming
together what did it mean to have
you know todd coming out uh front and
center
um as soon as the show began you know
that's the kind of position where you'd
see
phil come out and say his piece but you
know it was
it was it was your boy it was out there
what did that mean to you as a team and
what do you think it says
about bethesda's place within the xbox
family now
um there's a lot in there so um
i i thought the way in which we worked
together on the show was great
um we look we always
at bethesda our big thing is letting the
content decide what is the show gonna be
right if we had had an hour worth of
stuff that we felt like we needed to
show and talk about
we probably would have done our own show
because you can see from the xbox show
there's nowhere for
an hour of bethesda stuff on top of all
that this show would have been two and a
half hours long it would have been
a mess um once we decided hey it works
best for us to
collaborate together in this way we we
went to them and said hey this is
kind of how we'd like to do it would you
be open to this and they said absolutely
they were really the ones that said hey
we would love to start the show with
with todd and with starfield and we were
like that's a brilliant idea you should
um we pitched them on the idea of maybe
red fall closing the show
um they really liked that idea um as
well and so i think
the way in which we were able to work
together both on what is best for sort
of our games and spotlights and
covering off on things that we wanted to
to at least touch on or speak to
um and and have some weight within the
show but
then also still work with xbox on how
does the rest of this
um look at least from a first party
standpoint i don't get to see third
party stuff
um for obvious reasons but you know they
they
had you know myself and aaron loci in
from the very beginning going through
all their other studio content and
hey we're thinking about this or that it
was um it was really a lot of fun to
to see and to work with them and yeah i
think it's a real
honor for us to be honest to both open
and close a show that's a huge
amount of responsibility um and i was
really pleased that
you know i thought what we had to show
on star field i was really pleased with
obviously you'd love to be able to say
here's the whole game and it's done and
i can just show you the whole thing but
that's games on out till next year so we
we
wanted to stick with what we knew we had
and could talk about and
being able to show something in engine
and game assets i think for starfield
was super important to us
and the reaction so far has been has
been great it's very pleased
pleasing to see yeah yeah i mean like
you
certainly started with the showstopper
starfield i think a lot of people were
thinking that would be the thing that
ends it which
so when it came up up front i think a
lot of people were like oh snap that's
that's
awesome again a similar kind of question
um
what was it like to have that game out
there finally
in a more meaningful way we saw a tease
last year
you know it's a game that bethesda has
multiple times even in the trailer said
it's a game that's 25 years in the
making
um what does that really mean what is
that phrase kind of like
what does it represent again
yeah what are you talking about when you
say 25 years in the making
todd has talked about this a lot and i
think that's the important context
to have which is as he's thought about
it you know they they were working on
the elder scrolls when i first got to
bethesda in 99 that's that's what we
were known
for they always wanted to do more than
just
you know sort of classic um high fantasy
role playing
uh post-apocalyptic was the next place
that they wanted to go
and the way in which we approached that
was
getting the fallout license they're like
well we can go do our own thing but if
you could get us fallout that's the game
we really want to
make another one of like we want to
continue that franchise and so we went
and got that the other game they wanted
to go to after those two
was a sci-fi game you know it was
something that todd had tinkered with
himself back when he was coding and
making games
but i think to do the kind of game they
wanted
um and the kind of game that you would
expect from the folks that made fallout
4 fallout 3 skyrim oblivion morrowind
to make a sci-fi game it was a
it was a tech lift in terms of being
able to represent that in a way that
you know you heard talk about it at the
start of the show that transformative
thing right that
it wasn't enough just to do a game in
space that it
it wanted to do a game a sci-fi game
where you really
felt like this is this is real this is a
real
place um which is honestly um you know
the the comments that i paid the most
attention to
um because well i want to see five more
minutes well i would have loved to have
given you five more minutes if we had it
i'm sure
we would have shown it it's not like we
just arbitrarily don't show great
gameplay because
we're trying to be difficult i think
what we had to show and
showing folks the inside of that ship
and
all of the sort of lived-in qualities of
it right and i saw a lot of people
talking about you know
it feels like you're watching somebody
actually about to
launch a ship and all of the components
and the little notes or
the wear and tear on it like well i
think that's part of what that team
does really well which is a a sense of
place that felt like a real location
that you would really sit in and
and launch a ship and that you know
pieces of tape and things get
knocked up that they they have a sense
not just of how it looks but also
how it will work um like no these
buttons all have to do something you
can't just be
punching buttons and flipping things and
getting into that level of detail
requires a lot of things that quite
honestly the team didn't feel like they
had
until until now to be able to execute on
what they had envisioned right
i guess it's tricky from like the the
the side that i'm on
as someone who is really interested in
the game and fans who are interested in
the game
it's difficult because and it's
difficult for you as well as a team
where once you show
a small amount of it it's basically like
opening the floodgates and there's
demand for it now and they want to see
it so i guess the question for that
becomes like
what is the do you have an idea of the
cadence of how much you're gonna show
and when you're gonna show
more of it obviously right now
everyone's just like but what is the
gameplay when will we see the gameplay
and those questions are going to be
incessant and lingering until you show
the gameplay so do you have a plan in
place for when
it's looking like you might show it more
um are you able to say where might be
you
like otherwise i'm showing up to work
every day and being like hey anybody
want to say anything about starfield
today or like of course we've got a plan
but that plan as i said before is 100
based on where's the game at
because we're a big believer in not just
telling you about it but
showing to you right yesterday the
importance of that was not that we told
you about that stuff but we said hey
in engine this is the game this is what
we're making it's alpha
so you know don't judge us too harshly
but this is the thing we're making
and we want it to feel like and look
like to give folks that sense i just
don't think you can
shortcut that we put out another tone
piece today you know it shows off more
concept art and gives even
you know a little bit more of what the
team is trying to
create with this game um but it's
you know we got a ways to go and uh you
know we have thoughts around
timing for when we want to talk about
things and show things but ultimately it
has to be is the game ready to show that
feature because if not
it doesn't matter whether you want to or
not you can't you can't show folks this
is what it like
means to play the game or to see this
part of the game or that part of the
game we need to be able to
show it to you right i guess one of the
big discussion points that exists around
starfield now is
the xbox and pc exclusivity is finally
confirmed
um and i guess the question around that
is
at what point did that become a
consideration for you in
over the course of development within
bethesda itself and how did it
impact the both the development and also
as someone as something that you would
know particularly like your plans for
marketing because you obviously go from
speaking to a massive base of customers
to kind of focusing it down a bit right
when did that become a consideration how
did you approach that
um well it wasn't a consideration until
we got bought by xbox um
and then as part of xbox and we looked
at
what we were doing um it is going to be
exclusive on pc and within the
xbox ecosystem and i think it's
important to to phrase it like that only
because
you know recently within the last week
phil has talked about how they're
looking to expand that
right and and other ways they're looking
to bring xbox gaming to folks
who don't own a series s or x or even a
pc
but want to play the kinds of games that
you know we're bringing to game pass and
we're bringing
to xbox so um where wherever and however
that xbox ecosystem expands obviously
we're
you know we're excited about that the
flip side the the other thing you asked
about is like what is the impact on
development
well i'm here to tell you and any dev
will tell you this
you go to fewer platforms your
development gets more streamlined
you're not worrying about well how does
it work on this box versus how does it
work on that box
we're not making it on that box so it
just needs to run as
well as possible on this one on a pc
you know narrow focus always uh helps
same is true by the way for a game like
death loop right when we decided to do a
partnership with with sony on on death
loop and that game became exclusive to
that platform
that development got more streamlined
because we said ps5 and pc that's what
we're focusing on
um so i think in that way it does free
up the developers a little bit
in terms of what they're trying to get
the thing to be the best game on
when you have fewer of those it's gonna
go a little better i'm like you
mentioned death loop there and it's
it's kind of a wild position that
bethesda is in right now because you
owned by
microsoft and xbox but you have
exclusive games for both
platforms now which is which is
interesting and awkward and
i don't know this question is a tricky
one to answer but i still think it's
kind of important like
how i'm sure you can do it because
you're a master of answering questions
like this but um the the kind of reality
of the situation
is you know bethesda has released games
on various other platforms and
um now they're in a position where you
know they felt supported in a lot of
ways like skyrim's been on everything
fallout's been on everything
dishonored that kind of stuff but now
they're in a situation where that
investment
in their platform is kind of gone with
starfield how
it's a difficult pill to swallow right
for playstation fans how do you
how do they reconcile what's happening
given where they are
if you're a big fan of stuff we make in
a game that we're making is no longer
available on your platform
i totally understand if you're unhappy
or pissed or
whatever like i get it those are all
real
feelings and frustrations how should you
deal with that i have
i haven't the foggiest idea i would
never presume to say oh here's how you
can
make it better and feel better at the
same time
um you know there's only so much time i
can spend on
being focused on what we're not doing
right i'm trying to focus on
yes we're not but the actual problem is
we are making it for these other
platforms
and how is that going and where are we
and when are we ready to talk about
to your previous question these
different elements of the game and what
does that plan look like and do we need
to evolve the plan or change the plan
based on
the timing of things coming into the
game or when they're when they're ready
to show so
i tend to focus a little bit more on the
like well that i can solve that i can
have a conversation around
should we talk how are we going to talk
about this feature how are we going to
explain how this part of the game works
um
because of those are things like i just
i don't know how to allay the fears and
concerns of playstation 5 fans other
than to say
well i'm a playstation 5 player as well
and i've played games on that console
and there's games i'm going to continue
to to play on it um but you know if you
want to play star field
pc and xbox sorry i
yeah all i can really say is i apologize
um because i'm certain that that's
frustrating to folks but
um there's not a whole lot i can do
about it it's a good thing that
microsoft makes game pass
such a compelling proposition that kind
of you know now more than ever if
the idea of getting into the xbox
ecosystem is so appealing
and speaking of game pass um as a
company as
as someone who's been within bethesda
how has your
kind of perception of game pass changed
if at all because
it's gone from being this kind of
interesting idea to
like absurdly successful extremely
quickly right
it's like absolutely successful yeah
it's like unreal
well you can trace it all back to one
decision um which
predates us joining xbox i haven't even
gotten around to asking anybody like hey
how did this happen to come about
but all of the folks who decided hey
we're gonna start putting gay art
studio titles in game past day one
when they're also available for sale
that changed everything
it's it's remarkable how different game
passes now when you understand that
like you don't have to wait because the
old way of doing it would have been like
well a year from now
you know maybe that game gets added or
two years from now even our own
participation was always
well post launch you know they would say
hey what do you think about putting you
know fallout this or a doom that
into game pass or eso but it was always
well after that content came out and
shifting to
game pass day one and how many people
are gonna play your titles you know the
number of folks we've seen
going into games like prey or dishonored
or
doom 64 or whatever it is is remarkable
and getting to now talk to that game
pass team
and really all of xbox as a first party
which is still weird to say um
and just learning how they think about
it and approach it and and what game
pass can do for your title in terms of
player base and um and people active in
your game
uh is is pretty amazing um
and i'm super excited for where they are
and i'm
even more excited for where they're
heading and what they have planned like
you said i i just think it's
it's an obscene value somebody said to
me on social media the other day like
you could spend a lot of time trying to
find every bethesda title that you might
want for you know for your collection or
you just sign up the game pass and
like almost everything they've made is
sitting in there
waiting to be played it's it's a
ridiculous value on top of everything
else
that that comes out um and it's in there
so uh i've
i've become a massive fan i mean i was a
subscriber to game pass before but i
would sort of graze it
i play a ton of it now especially the x
cloud stuff i find that
um to be a really fun way to be able to
take my games
um with me and uh i've been using it a
ton
over the last six seven months did the
conversation
around it change from the bethesda side
in the same way that it did for
people who are on the outside looking at
it you know like people looked at and
they were like i'm not going to show if
this is work the idea of
launching games into it seems like it's
weird and could that really hamper the
performance of a game to now where it's
like
it makes perfect sense was it similar in
the case of you where you're like
do we want to be putting star field on
this for free basically
to now being like oh it makes perfect
sense 100
like for sure because if you don't
understand it then you don't understand
the mechanics of what's taking place
behind the curtain
how are player behaviors actually
manifesting themselves
versus you or me or anybody else going
well i assume if it's in game pass
nobody's going to buy it
and they go no no hold on let us show
you what we've seen from these
like that's what really proved it is
they had this idea and then they proved
hey we can launch something day one in
game pass
and of course there's some
cannibalization it's ridiculous to
suggest otherwise right i haven't bought
a first party
xbox title in a couple of years because
when gears came out
i just played it through game pass and
when halo comes out i'm just playing it
through game pass
um but when you look at the larger
picture of the sheer volume of people
playing your game
and how they engage with your um content
and how game pass is doing like it's
honestly bethesda's mantra
in all of the almost 22 years i've been
here is pretty simple we want to make
great games and we want as many people
to play it as possible now okay put
aside the exclusive thing
for a half a second because we already
talked about that but the number of
people game pass now brings to a title
and what your day one launches look like
in terms of just
how many people are playing your game um
it's multiple factors you know above
where we
would have been before and the idea of
that many people
playing your game on the day that it
comes out is
ultimately what we're all about right
it's just i want lots and lots of people
to play
whatever arcane austin has spent years
of their lives working on
i want a ton of people to to play it
enjoy it
give it a try and i think game pass is
allowing us to do that
exponentially better than we were before
i think
phil said it um himself where you know
it has an uplifting effect on purchases
as well as people
buying it you know and outriders was
used as kind of like the example of that
where
people saw their friends getting into
our writers through game pass and we're
like well i don't have game pass so i
guess i'll have to buy it and then
it's a very clever funnel and uh you
gotta respect the business acumen put
behind that
um yeah absolutely honestly we've seen
it we've seen it in eso and 76 by the
way tomorrow like that
that not only are people buying the game
but also just staying in the game like
we might think of it as well you're
getting that for free but that's not how
they
think about it they think i'm signing up
for this thing and i'm going to spend
untold number of hours playing things
that are in game pass
and and it really has changed how we
think about those players and our
relationship to them
in our games uh riddle uh
really interesting concept i guess my
main question
with that game is from what the trailer
was really fascinating the one thing i
was kind of looking for in it is
how the kind of arcane lineage or arcane
design ethos is going to be represented
in the game obviously they're known for
immersive sims is there anything you can
say or speak to about how that will be
the case
is it is it is it the case that it will
have that
absolutely yeah look this is an
evolution
uh by their own admission of arcane
austin and how they think about those
kinds
of games right and if you think about
what they do
how do you break down a dishonored or
prey into sort of basic fundamental
levels what they're doing
well one is very much non-scripted right
they're
big believers in systems based games
where they create some systems and they
put them all together and then whatever
the player wants to do
in those worlds whatever however they
want to try and approach different
situations is entirely okay
right you want to jump off a giant
building and dishonored and before you
splat on the ground manage to possess a
fish
and suddenly be swimming in the water
like that's not a gameplay intended
feature that was a tester
who figured out that the systems in the
game allowed them to do it and then
arcane said
not we got to take that out because
you're going to break the game we said
well now we got to support
if you manage to possess a fish and what
right what is the player now going to do
so
in a lot of those same ways red fall is
very similar
it's um you know it's systems based um
arcane does a great job of creating a
sense of place whether it's in prey or
dishonored
it feels like a a very realistic
tangible
world and i think that's the case in red
fall
and then just the way that they've gone
about approaching
the gameplay whether you're playing it
by yourself you know you can play it
essentially single player solo it and
play it by
yourself or you can play it with other
folks but it's going to
very much you're going to feel that
arcane dna as you're playing through the
game with
how the game works you know they've
talked about ever changing the idea is
that
that you know you're in a game world
that really isn't ever the same
every every time you play it you're
getting something different that the
world is changing
from the last time you played it in ways
that are meaningful from a gameplay
standpoint
like that that a certain location isn't
always the same thing
every single time you play the game the
one time you played it might be one
thing and the next time you play it it
might be something else and
how you interact with that whether
there's a quest related to it whether
there's stuff in there you want to go
get
for exploration it's really more give
the player
the tools and then let them experience
our story in the way that they want to
experience it
and and have it be feeling like it's
constantly changing
evolving and i think once you get a
chance to play it you're going to be
like
i totally see where all that arcane dna
is popping its head up across all these
different parts of the game
honestly i'm glad that you going for
vampires instead of the low hanging
fruit these days which is zombies
i'm very excited about that the other
thing i wanted to kind of
touch on is what wasn't there machine
games
a massive studio for you um great studio
that uh produces some excellent games um
what does the a lot of people especially
in our community
very excited to figure out or understand
or see what the future of
wolfenstein looks like is there anything
you can tell us about
you know where that franchise is at and
where even the studio machine games is
that is it time for them to look
elsewhere or is it
you know they're working on a few things
so um
they're working they're working on the
indiana jones game that we
we just talked about earlier this year
and obviously
we literally just announced that deal so
you can
make your own guesses at how far along
that game is they're in the very very
very early stages
of working on the indiana jones game um
where we are for wolfenstein or quite
honestly any other franchise that we
don't have announce plans on
i'll have to wait until we get to the
point of wanting to talk about it but
you can put me at the head of the list
of people who
want to see another wolfenstein game so
no no worries there
i imagine it's a creative team a lot of
people are like let's do something new
and different
but at the same time the fans are out
there being like i want a new
wolfenstein i want another doom i want
another
dishonored i want another xyz game how
do you how do you approach finding that
balance especially now that you're
owned by microsoft and also you're
working i think we'll have to find out
because again what you have to remember
is we didn't have teams sitting around
doing nothing waiting for us to be
acquired by xbox so that we can then
figure out okay let's figure out what
you're going to work on next right
bgs is already working on starfield then
they're going to make test six
uh zenimax online is doing eso they've
talked about they're working on another
project
we haven't talked about what it is up to
is they've you know finished doing
updates and support for doom eternal
but machine games is doing um indiana
jones we just announced arcane austin's
red fall
arcane leone is working on death loop um
tango was working on
ghostwire so if you go through our
studios you actually find
oh yeah i know what most of them are
actively working on
right now so we don't have a lot of
folks sitting around going well let's
make something new and should it be a
sequel or should it be a new ip
um we just not at a point
in this moment to start saying okay
what's ever
like because we already have plans that
have been laid out for what are these
studios doing
for years at a time and one of the
things xbox said was
we are not messing with what you're
doing or what you have going on
so there's been no change to any of our
current plans because
their thing is just do what you're
planning on doing
and you know we want to work with you
obviously we want to understand what
those are
right like they're not just like oh red
fall you know
matt booty is always like hey how's it
going and you know talking to harvey
smith so
you know those conversations are
happening but we're not really having
the
what is studio x gonna work on next
because
everybody already knows what they're
working on for the next
number of years so i think those things
will end up manifesting themselves as as
we go along
final question very quickly you
mentioned there what's the deal with
ghostwater tokyo when we're going to see
that again please pete i'm begging you
let it out
let it come out and play uh i don't know
the hardwood drives it the content
drives it and when we feel like that
game is
is ready you know we've got plans but
all those plans are based on dev
and as you know nobody's development is
going exactly the same as when we were
all in the office together so
you know we have to be patient and let
teams
take the time to make what they're
planning on making in very different
circumstances than we've been dealing
with for the last
year and a half pete thank you so much
for your time and thank you so much for
being part of
us if you want to keep your eyes on
gamespot.com you will be
treated with plenty more e3 coverage
content stay tuned
see you soon
[Music]
do
[Music]
you